there are real questions about Jill
Stein and connections to Russia but I've
not really talked about them because
what quite frankly I don't really care
about Jill Stein I find Jill Stein
irrelevant and unqualified to be
President of the u.s. Bernie Sanders on
the other hand while I have a number of
criticisms of Bernie Sanders I don't
find Bernie to be irrelevant and
unqualified and there's now a Hillary
Clinton adviser named Adam Parkhomenko
who alleged on Twitter that Bernie
Sanders may have colluded with Russia I
told you last week about those leaked
portions of Hillary Clinton's upcoming
book what happened is the name of the
book and some parts of her book relate
directly to Bernie Sanders which makes
sense and Adam Parker menko sent a
series of three tweets and in those he
sort of mentioned that he believes
Bernie might be tied to Russia in a sort
of PS in his third tweet I'll read the
series of three tweets to you starting
with ready for Hillary was a movement
was proud to run the PAC we didn't sell
those also how could Bernie have won
when Bernie lost so much vacant news do
you go to bed at night praying a fake
Democrat runs again in 2020 Brady amber
Magnitsky sanctions PS you seem to
ignore the Russia support online for
Bernie during the primaries the guy is
hiding something not sure I want to know
what what on earth is this about it
seems like it's very out of left field a
couple people emailed me they said David
Parker Mancos Ukrainian Ukrainian
American so that's why he's saying this
I think more relevant to me is that
parca menko was recently rehired by
hillary clinton to help manage onward
together which is this new project that
she started in the spring with former
governor howard dean and it's meant to
fund and support a coalition of
democratic groups so listen last week
when I criticized Hillary Clinton for
some of the things she said about Bernie
in the primary uh I said it seemed like
she just kind of didn't get a lot of
what happened bunch of people wrote in
and they slammed me a couple people
canceled their membership saying David
you're too anti hill
for me I'm not supporting you anymore
sorta seems to go with the territory my
bigger concern is that this type of
stuff will implode the Democratic Party
even more because we have a situation
that should be a win win win win in 2018
and 2020 and that being said because of
lack of enthusiasm from the electorate
as a whole and a whole host of other
reasons I gave you the math last week or
the week before Trump could win
reelection with just 35% presidential
approval so when I start seeing this
stuff Oh Bernie might have been the one
who actually colluded with Russia from a
former and I guess kind of current
Hillary operative if not advisor what
are the Democrats doing yeah especially
if you're not going to bring any
supporting evidence right I mean you're
not direct not just an essentially he's
just saying that he doesn't actually
have anything to back himself up three
people who as far as I know don't know
each other
wrote me very similar emails over the
weekend saying David you know what this
is about right this entire Bernie
colluded with Russia thing is the
Bernie's an old commie Jew thing and I
honestly don't know about that it was
interesting that three different people
wrote to me saying this is just a
Bernese and old commie Jew that's all
that this is it's an ad hominem on him
and also he's saying that how could
Bernie have won if he lost does he not
understand that the primaries in the
general election are two completely
different things yes and in the latter
one you don't have an apparatus a
private apparatus like the DNC playing
favorites uh well they s they're playing
favorites but they presumably support
the Democrat but ya know you're right
the DNC's influence was in the primary
but by and large very weird and I'm
gonna continue seeing whether that we
ever get an explanation from mr. Parker
menko about where he came up with this
stuff